Lady pepettes sortir disco texte de
Christine no man Villemin illustration
de Stéphane Sénégal
c'est l'histoire d'une sorcière méchante
très très méchante et affreuse vraiment
affreuse évidemment une seule chose
l'intéresse manger des enfants
mais comme elle est moche terriblement
moche les enfants se sauvent dès qu'il
la voit et elle n'en attrape jamais elle
a bien essayé d'en piéger deux en les
attirant dans sa maison en pain d'épices
mais ce n'était pas une très bonne idée
les deux garnements l'ont enfermé dans
le four et lui ont volé ses économies
elle décide alors de se rendre au
Congrès des sorcières qui est l'endroit
rêvé pour connaître les dernières
nouveautés en matière de pièges à
enfants que deviens-tu lui demande la
Fée Carabosse ça marche les affaires oh
là là dur dur ça fait une éternité que
je n'ai pas attrapé d'enfant ah les
temps changent interviennent la vieille
pustula les bonbons sont dépassés les
enfants d'aujourd'hui veulent des
paillettes du spectacle pour les attirer
il leur faut de l'exceptionnel du
stationnaire du show business du Grand
diose bref il faut les épater les
sidérer les scotchés
la sorcière prend des notes et sans
retourne chez elle avec un plan d'enfer
Grandin relooking grand 2 cours de chant
grand III cours de danse à l'institut de
beauté l'esthéticienne se désole oh là
là il y a du travail ma petite dame
depuis combien de temps n'avez-vous pas
fait de masques hydratant votre peau est
toute sèche et ses grands poils sur le
menton toute la semaine la sorcière se
fait pas touiller chouchouter pomponner
c'est dur mais à la fin le résultat lui
plaît
au conservatoire de la chanson la
professeure en a les oreilles échanchées
oh youyou il y a du boulot reprenez au
clair de la lune pour voir
non arrêtez toute la semaine notre
sorcière fait des mamie mommu des do ré
mi fa sol c'est dur mais à la fin le
résultat lui plaît à l'école de danse la
professeure en reste les bras ballants
et ben c'est pas gagné tourner un peu
pour voir les bras comme ça bon on
repart dans zéro savez-vous sont vos
pieds toute la semaine la sorcière fait
du hip-hop des claquettes du flamenco et
des petits sauts et arrêtez les
cacahuètes ordonne la danseuse vous avez
de trop grosses fesses la sorcière était
épuisée mais à la fin le résultat lui
plaît de retour chez elle la sorcière se
dit qu'il lui faut un nom de scène
quelque chose qui sonne bien facile à
retenir
Suzy Dolly Laurine zazette Lady Lady
pépettes oui ça c'est un nom toute
contente de sa trouvaille elle s'enferme
dans son salon et met au point un numéro
qu'elle répète sans relâche jusqu'à ce
qu'il soit parfait puis elle s'inscrit à
une émission de télévision
le grand jour arrive lorsque vient son
tour de monter sur la scène elle se
présente bonsoir chère publique je
m'appelle Lady pepette et je suis dans
ce chanteur ma chanson dansait
s'intitule vient dans ma maison tu
verras mon chaudron attention ça va
décoiffer alors elle se lance sur la
piste ça swing Saint-Roch sa claque elle
chauffe la salle vraiment quel style
qu'elle voit le succès est immédiat tout
le monde veut limiter les filles se
coiffent comme elles les garçons si sa
chanson on lui demande des autographes
des photos dédicacées des interviews un
matin on sonne à sa porte une petite
fille toute dodu et potelée pas comme
cette grande andouille de Gretel une
vraie maigrichonne celle-là
oh Lady je t'adore je suis depuis le
début de ta carrière youpi se dit la
sorcière mon plan a marché j'ai réussi
elle jubile enfin elle a réussi à tirer
un enfant je connais toutes les figures
par cœur continuent la fille être
regarde un pas en avant demi-tour les 10
approches doucement et se lèchent déjà
les babines claque des mains poursuit la
gamine les doigts crochus aux ongles
vernis se tendent vers la mignonne hum
petit mouvement du bassin pirouette à
gauche mais non à droite la pirouette
s'entend conseiller Lady vous êtes sûr
c'est quand même moi qu'il est inventé
cette chorégraphie et après demande la
petite fille après petit pas tourne la
tête une deux claques des doigts non pas
comme ça comme ça ah oui j'ai compris
tiens ce diletty et si j'en faisais une
danseuse elle pourrait être derrière moi
ça ferait pas mal dans mon spectacle bon
tiens oui d'accord bonne idée mais le
prochain enfant je le mange le lendemain
on sonne à la porte un petit garçon tout
mignon et très appétissant pas comme
cette grande asperge d'un seul qui
sentait le chou Lady s'écrit l'enfant
hystérique prends-moi dans ton show
regarde je danse hyper bien ah non ce
dilatant tiers celui-là je le boulotte
mais le gamin c'est déjà lancé dans une
démonstration ahurissante après tout il
serait pas mal dans mon numéro se dit
Lady bon mais le prochain juré craché je
le mange
le lendemain digne donc une classe de
CE1 tout entière envahi le perron quel
festin se réjouit les dit je vais même
pouvoir en surgeler oh Lady On adore ce
que tu fais dis le délégué de classe on
est venu pour apprendre les pas les 10
réfléchis quelques instants et une idée
lumineuse surgit dans son esprit et si
je montais une comédie musicale elle
s'intitulerait les 10 pépettes et les
pépites the show il y aurait des effets
spéciaux des danseurs sur ressort géants
des figures en volant les dix pepettes
rêvent la troupe irait en tournée à Las
Vegas puis dans le monde entier il y
aurait des vêtements Lady pépettes des
sacs et tipé pètes oui c'est ça je suis
géniale réflexion faite ce n'est pas
tellement intéressant de croquer les
enfants c'est gras et sucré et je n'ai
pas intérêt à prendre du poids si je
veux faire du cinéma